مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم مجددا في هذه
الحلقه الخاصه من برنامج حوار حيث الصديق
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
في قمه البحر الاحمر كيف ترى الموقف
الفرنسي من ايران
ولكن الرئيس
الاتصال
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
كما كان عليه منذ عام ونصف العام واليوم
وكما جدي اليه هنالك سلطات ايرانيه تخضع
للضغوطات من الثوره الشعبيه وهنالك اتفاق
نووي
وافاقه
السلبيات ثم هنالك الحوار السعودي
الايراني الذي لم يعطي ثماره ولدينا
الانتباه عن الايرانيين
الغربيه
ومن الطرف الاخر ليس هنالك افاق
الايجابيات تسمح بالتقدم على مسار
الاستقرار في المنطقه الذي يهم الفرنسي
نفوز الايراني يعني قوي في سوريا في لبنان
في العراق كما ذكرنا يعني
ااا اتطرق الى هذه الدول دوله دوله اليوم
العراق يعني العراق تعرض لضربات من ايران
على اراضيهم موجوده
قوات مباشره او غير مباشره او كونسيلتا
يعني مستشارين موجودين على الاراضي
العراقيه يعني اليوم العراقي يعني هو تحت
سيطره ايران ام لا
تاثير الايراني
العراق سوريا
واللي اموال هذه الدول الى
ايران مثلا او ماذا
يرسلون الاموال والاسلحه لهذه البلدان
ولكن على ما يبدو فان طريقه همم
حكم هذه البلدان الاقتصاديه
ليست مرضيه حتى الان وهذا
يفسرون
الايراني واضح في البلدان الاربعه التي
ذكرتها ولكن هذا التاثير ضعيف لانه
الاداره همم اداره الموارد الاقتصاديه
الشعب ونرى حركات شعبيه
مطالب الشعب
وفرنسا تحاول التدخل والرئيس مكروه اظهر
ان لبنان بالنسبه لنحن لنا نحن الفرنسيين
له اهميته نعم كان هنالك مبادره لم تعطي
نتائج
نعم
لبناني الذي اظهر في ثوره 2019
العلاقات
ذلك سيحصل عندما ااا تجرى الاصلاحات
الاساسيه
واا هنالك الاتفاق الغازي بين اسرائيل
ولبنان وانا اؤمن بالنهضه اللبنانيه ولكن
هنالك ضروره لحكومه ورئيس واصلاحات اساسيه
لبنان
واليوم الامر الماساوي هو انا الكثير من
شباب ذوي المؤهلات
له مستقبل في لبنان
ذهب الى سوريا سوريا وايران همم هناك نفوذ
ايراني داخل سوريا
مع
مستقبل هذا البلد وما مصير الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد
[موسيقى]
لا تسيطر الا على جزء من البلاد البلد
مقسم
دمشق والغرب تحت سيطره الحكومه الشمال
الشرقي سيطره
فسوريا كما عرفناها لم تعد موجوده ثانيا
الوضع الاقتصاديه
النظام ليست ليس قائما الا بفضل الدعم
الروسي والايراني وانظرنا الى وضع روسيا
ووضع ايران نتساءل هل هذا مستقبل البلد
اا بالنسبه للبلد لكن بالنسبه للرئيس
السوري
في الوقت الحالي الرئيس السوري يراس بلدا
اصبح مقبره فلا اعرف الى اي وقت سيدوم ذلك
طبعا هنالك ملون
معه لعدم وجود افضل ولكن هل هو قادر على
تحقيق النظر في بلده لست اكيده سننتقل الى
المغرب العربي
زياره الرئيس ايمن والمكرو الى الجزائر هل
تعتقد انها فتحت صفحه جديده مع الجزائر
والجزائريين خاصه فيما يتعلق بملابس
هنا هنا
رغبه قويه لدى الرئيس ماكرون
اه لتحقيق مصالحه تاريخيه بين فرنسا
والجزائر الامور حساسه وصعبه هنالك بعد
الذاكره ولكن الامر الاهم هو ان الجزائر
بلد جديد بلد مجاور لدينا معه علاقات
انسانيه وثقافيه وينبغي ان نتعاون معا
وهذا ما نرغب به
الامور تتطوره
ولكن نظرا للكارثه التي تحصل في روسيا فان
الاصدقاء
الجزائريين سيعدون النظر في ذلك سنبقى في
المغرب العربي وسنذهب الى المملكه
المغربيه يعني العلاقات بين باريس الرباط
امم حصل اه اه فطور للاسباب التي ذكرتيها
ولكن اليوم
حصلت عده حوارات بين الملك المغربي
والرئيس ماكرون
حوارات واعده هنالك زياره لوزير الخارجيه
لتحضير زياره الرئيس الفرنسي
الى علاقات قويه كالسابق والمغرب بالنسبه
لنا بلد له اهميه كبيره همم
البلد الذي يعيش واقعا افضل من غيره في
بلدان المغرب العربي لديه طموح في افريقيا
وهو شريك
قائم بذاته
طموح همم ولا يمكننا الا ان نحيي انجاز
فريق اسود الاطلس الذي اظهروا ان المغرب
بلد ديناميكي طموح وهو شريك هام بالنسبه
عاشت فتره يعني من التشنج السياسي الداخلي
انتخابات وحل البرلمان وما الى ذلك كيف
ترى مستقبل تونس
تابعوا باهتمام كبير الوضع في تونس تونس
لطالما كانت بلدا مثاليه
بلدا ناجحا اقتصاديا وديمقراطيا واليوم
نرى ان الوضع الاقتصادي صعب في تونس يعني
كثيره من التونسيين لا يخفوننا ان الوضع
صعب وهمم
اقتصادي صعب اما العلاقات الاقتصاديه
مع تونس فانها ممتازه ولكن هنالك قلق
اتجاه ان نزع الاستبداديه للنظام هنا ومن
الطبيعي بالنسبه لبلد
فرنسا وهي وطن حقوق الانسان ان تنظرها في
هذا الامر هذا ليس تدخل وانما هو قول
الحقيقه همم تقولون بالعربيه صديقك من
صدقك اليس كذلك
صح هل ما زال هناك دور لفرنسا في ليبيا
التي ترى نفوذا تركيا متزايده
في سقوط النظام القذافي الديكتاتوري ولكن
النتيجه ليست كما تمنيناه
والليبيا اليوم بلد مقسم عندما يكون مقسما
وفيه امراء وحروب يكون هنا تدخل خارجي
وتدخل الخارجي طبعا همم
من طرف في تركيا التي لديها طموحات همم
اقليميه
منها هي ليست وحده وحدها روسيا ايضا تتدخل
في ليبيا وفي بلدان اخرى في افريقيا مالي
افريقيا
فلنتظر نتائج الانتخابات والشعب التركي هو
الذي سيبث بالامر ولكن نظرا للوضعي
الاقتصادي
ونظرا للنزعه الاستبداديه للنظام التركي
لا يمكن ان ننكر ان المعارضه ربما لديها
فرصه اكبر على كل الشعب التركي هو الذي
يقرر
ولماذا تعرضت
لكل هذه الانتقادات التي رايناها في
الغربه
همم
مفرطه ولا داعي لها
فانظرنا الى النجاح الذي همم
حققته قطر في تنظيم المونديال الذي اسعد
الملايين في انحاء العالم همم لا ينبغي
الخلط بين الرياضه والسياسه طبعا قطر قطر
بين نشاط الضغط والفساد غير واضح العداله
هي التي ستموت طبعا
هذا ليس همم حجه
للقيام بما لا تم القيام به ان نظرنا الى
قطر منذ 50 عاما والى قطر اليوم نعم قطر
لديها ثروات ولكن هنالك بلدان اخرى لديها
اموال ولديها نفط وليست بنفسي جوده اداره
قطر لا يمكن النظر التي نجحت في تنظيم كاس
العالم
من السلام والحوار
والتفاؤل بدون تفاؤل قصير صعبه
الى مشاهدين ابي التحيه واتمنى لكم اعيابا
سعيده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]